♪ ♪ ♪
- Montréalais, Montréalaises,
vous reconnaissez ce bâtiment.
Pendant des années, l'usine
Canada Malting a servi à
transformer l'orge en malt.
À l'abandon, depuis plus
de 30 ans, le bâtiment est
aujourd'hui un emblême du
quartier Saint-Hen
- C'est le vestige de
l'histoire industrielle, qui
est très importante là, ici.
- Noam Schnitzer veut
lui donner une seconde vie.
Il veut, notamment, construire
des logements sociaux et
familiaux dans l'ancien complexe
et ses gigantesques silos.
L'obtention des permis et
un changement de zonage
freinent les ardeurs du
développeur immobilier.
Mais le temps presse...
NOAM SCHNITZER, développeur
immobilier
- Le bâtiment est très
détérioré. Il faut réagirassez .
- Le dossier est complexe,
plusieurs acteurs sont impliqués
et tous se renvoient la balle.
BEAUDET, professeur
urbanisme Université de Montréal
- La valeur patrimoniale, elle
est affirmée par tout le monde,
mais c'est comme s
ne voulait vraiment l'assumer
pleinement en disant :
"Bon, bien il y a une valeur
patrimoniale, il faut qu'on
relève nos manches, il faut
qu'on trouve une solution."
- Laissez-nous tous collaborer,
laissez-nous tout mettre
ensemble et trouve
d'aller en avant.
- Le cas de la Malting Co.
est loin d'être unique.
Un autre exemple, celui du silo
r N5. Construit au
tournant du 20e siècle, il
se dégrade depuis des décennies.
- On voit bien, là, qu'on joue
sur deux registres. On dit "Oui,
ça a une valeur patrimoniale",
mais on ne prend pas les
moyens, d'abord, de protéger
efficacement, puis ensuite,
de trouver un usag
- Chaque dossier est différent.
Dans d'autres cas, le promoteur
néglige volontairement le
bâtiment. Avec le temps, la
démolition devient inévitable,
parce que ce qui les intéresse,
c'est le terrain. Et puis, il
y a la stratégie du façadisme;
seule la façade de bâtiment
reste en place et on construit
derrière.
- Au lieu d'être une exception,
c'est devenu une habitude.
- Dans son plus rért,
le conseil du patrimoine de
Montréal dénonce cette pratique
de plus en plus courante.
Un phénomène qui cache souvent
la densification urbaine, selon
Peter Jacobs.
PETER JACOBS, président, Conseil
du patrimoine de Montréal
- La densification pourrait
se faire tout en faisant
la conservation de patrimoine
et sa mise en valeur, mais s'il
est fait avec soin.
- On peut pas dire une chose
et faire son contraire.
Il faut être cohérent.
Si il y a un secteur de grande
valeur patrimoniale, bien
c'est pas là qu'on doit faire
de la densification.
- Il faut la concertation
de tous les gouvernements,
selon lui. Mais il y a
peut-être un peu d'espoir;
Québec dévoilera sa toute
première politique nationale
d'architecture et d'aménagement
du territoire en 2022.
Quelle importance donnera-t-on
au patrimoine québécois?
Les experts sont impatients
de le savoir.
Ici Kim Vermette,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.